[Music]
one of the most important things in our
experience as humans is connection the
idea that you're safe that it's gonna
last companions are not going to leave
use important to me the mission comes up
with the probability of two people
staying together your chances for a
successful relationship were 75 percent
congratulations so I have to show you
something in a very real way were
teaching him how to feel
sir God wants to start my socialization
immediately asked him if I could learn
to dance good ID what if I told you I am
a synthetic what if I told you I could
engage your emotions and sense what
you're feeling better than anyone in
this room I wonder all the time if you
think about me I thought
[Music]
I'll never break your heart I believe
you I am designed to love you and
understand you in ways that humans
simply can't you know this has been done
seeing someone else
Xero's England missions don't really
feel the way people do yeah
match our compatibility your chances of
a successful relationship before
disappearing are 0% there is a
fundamental incompatibility
what is this call this isn't gonna be
easy to say there was a test I'm so
sorry sir
this is my life it doesn't make any
sense
I'd like us to be a couple
well you guys had together as real
mystery
[Music]
please call I need to know what will
happen to you and me
[Music]
you
[Music]
you